jika gap vibration collaboration hard
day of work always messy soul in that
quarry our first year of being global we
thought we would actually go to world
tour and just meet directly with these
three designers I just wanted to go over
this one more time I'm getting a little
antsy I think I'm pretty much signed on
but I just wanted to have another
discussion with you about it I mean I
think that's the coolest thing about
this is just just kind of introduce a
new audience to who you people are
let's head over to the gap and show them
what we got yeah this is part of our big
reveal walk down the streets of New York
with these I think we have three really
amazing candidates three designers
drumroll for the first letter Garrett's
gonna pass for me it's for amazing
it's on me I mean it's just he's just a
perfect designer he is the master of
subtlety that is a color that only the
French can do yes but not the right not
the right fabric yet another right color
completely in process this is the first
time I see the busiest Good Shepherd we
just need to yeah perfect I want to be
it'll be perfect he is just like all the
fun and color and life and friends
now we're gonna go even farther
we're gonna go to Asia we have chosen
united arrows hoagie and must come
Ishida they're definitely stars their
own right in the fashion sphere oh go
samosa Rachel the edge of this girl I
think what makes united arrow special is
that you got pogey mr. cover she his own
personal style and you're gonna see that
in the clothes we looked at the Japanese
for their incredible individuality we
look to them for their cool factor maybe
in Tokyo is really just about getting
some style dust shut upon us that's the
way to wear khaki suit they always
disrupt the style message they go subtle
and we go wild and they go wild me go
subtle one more okay so supposed to be a
backwards K it's info when we think
about kinfolk you think about graphics
and color they were really one of the
first ones to open a store in this
really specific area that is now since
become like all of the cool places to be
so compound the cafe was full nightclub
in the back
when you see me when you're done their
lifestyle heating up the weather get
your feeling so let's go - out - my
sauce in the building with chinko shout
out to it living the way into will like
to use fashion as a canvas we love the
culture [ __ ] approve so rough Harrison
Tokyo yep am Brooklyn here in Paris
we're gonna go over and see on me and
check out with these all Bob you didn't
want to make something crazy forget I
kind of like that I've never done that
before
[Music]